[Musik]
bern anfang der 90er jahre direkt vor
dem bundeshaus hat sich die offene
drogenszene mit all ihrem elend
ausgebreitet
damals habe ich markus kennengelernt
nicht begleitete ihn in seinem junkie
alltag
zu sein
bald darauf wurde die szene vor dem
bundeshaus polizeilich geräumt
markus und die drogensüchtigen wichen in
den berner kurpark aus
doch die szene wurde immer größer und
die verunsicherte bevölkerung forderte
konkrete lösungen von den politikern der
stadt versuchte der offenen drogenszene
zu begegnen und begann heroin an
schwerstabhängige
und die kontrollierte drogen abgabe coda
kennengelernt
er war bereits seit zehn jahren auf der
gasse und gehörte zu den ersten junkies
die an diesem versuch teilnahmen zweimal
täglich erhielt markus hier unter
ärztlicher betreuung heroin vom staat
die leiterin der kontrollierten drogen
abgabe hat das berner oder mit aufgebaut
barbara mühlheim erinnert sich an die
situation anfang der 90er jahre
vertraglichen formalitäten
erfolg ich behandle
damals 1996 habe ich die vier cola
benutzer der ersten stunde über ein jahr
lang mit der kamera begleitet
heute mehr als zehn jahre später will
ich wissen wie es ihnen in der
zwischenzeit ergangen ist
markus ist der erste den ich wieder
treffe er bezieht eine iv rente und es
dem moment drogenfrei markus plant jetzt
eine reise nach asien wo er seine
ausbildung als tauchlehrer abschließen
will
das ist zusammen 1996 schwer
heroinabhängig
heute ist susan 33 weg vom heroin aber
alkohol süchtig und chronisch krank
auch michelle war 1996 heroinsüchtig als
einzige der vier hat der 32-jährige den
ausstieg aus dem drogengeschäft
heute für einen kulturbetrieb den er
ganz alleine aufgebaut hat
er will ihn ist jetzt 52 jahre alt sie
bezieht als einzige noch er ihn vom
staat trotzdem geht sie einer
regelmäßigen arbeit nach und sie
musiziert
[Musik]
56 also wenn ich meine
zukunft
dort
auch evelyn habe ich in den 90er jahren
kennengelernt
1996 wurde sie ausgewählt an der
nationalen drogenkontrolle als
vertreterin der junkies eine rede zu
halten ich traf evelyn zu hause wo sie
an ihrem text arbeitete an diesem für
sie so wichtigen tag wollte sie den
politikern von ihren nöten als
heroinsüchtige erzählen
aktive auf der off szene auf ich lernte
was sie sich einnehmen zu sein und sich
nirgends aufhalten zu dürfen
nun habe ich aber das glück seit monaten
an kontrollierte dunkel abgabe programm
teilzunehmen
für mich bedeutet dies dass ich von der
gasse welt kann mich körperlich erholt
und jetzt wieder eine ziemlich
geregelten tagesablauf und seit kurzem
auch eine arbeit nachgehen kann ich zum
beispiel brauchen zurzeit noch die stars
die wäre die medaillen gibt um überleben
zu können
ich rede zu wenig als mensch und nicht
versuchen sie doch mehr als mensch
zuzuhören nicht dass fachperson oder
politiker da
berlin fand in jener zeit trotz ihrer
sucht eine stelle in einer
genossenschaftsbank ich bin überrascht
sie heute immer noch dort anzutreffen
obwohl
sie einen geregelten alltag hat braucht
sie auch heute noch täglich heroin aus
der drogen abgabe oder
[Musik]
ich weiß
nach wie vor was muss die saison quasi
zum cottbus trägt also ob
43 und der 30 minütige gross gehandelt
susan ging einen anderen weg
sie lebt mit ihrem hund pablo in einer
kleinen anderthalb zimmer wohnung auf
dem land susan ist weg vom heroin aber
ihr alltag wird seither bestimmt durch
alkoholkonsum und chronische krankheiten
sie bezieht eine iv-rente
als ich sie vor über 10 jahren
kennenlernte war sie 22 jahre jung sie
hatte sehr früh begonnen proben zu
konsumieren damals lebte sie schon vier
jahre in bern auf der gasse
tagtäglich war susann dem stress
ausgesetzt sich mit prostitution und
dielen neue drogen beschaffen zu müssen
um diesem elend zu entkommen beschloss
sie 1996 in die kontrollierte drogen
abgabe coda einzutreten
[Musik]
susan lebte damals mit ihrem freund rolf
in einer gemeinsamen wohnung diese
beziehung war für sie sehr wichtig
margaret court der uni st
[Musik]
der minister
morgen aufsteht start strässer und haben
biss organisiert
bis heute hat sie ihren rolf nicht
vergessen
als ich mich vor über zehn jahren zum
ersten mal im tor traf war 21 jahre jung
soo ausgaben
nur der sieg
damals habe ich ihn auf dem weg zu
seinem elternhaus begleitet die
heroinsucht hat er seine beziehungen zu
eltern und freunden fast zerstört die
kontrollierte heroinabgabe
ermöglichte es ihm schrittweise wieder
in ein geregeltes leben zurückzufinden
und langsam das vertrauen zu seinem
früheren umfeld wieder aufzubauen
[Musik]
es ist vielleicht mit
substanz bereue meine mikrometer ja vor
der haustür um dauert es sich aus
gefährdeten
spezies
markus ist heute 52 jahre alt positiv
und bezieht eine iv-rente ich treffe ihn
meistens in seinem stammlokal gleich
gegenüber von seiner wohnung seit ich
ihn kenne lebte im selben man sagen
zimmer im moment ist er drogenfrei aus
seinem beruf als goldschmied ist er vor
mehr als 20 jahren ausgestiegen er
träumt davon tauchlehrer auf bali zu
werden
[Musik]
vor über zehn jahren zeigte mehr markus
zum ersten mal seine wohnung ihr zustand
verriet mir jeweils wie es ihm gerade
ging
etappe
führt die fahrer
wo immer er auch nicht süchtig und
martina stetter
so ist nach wie vor
ungeklärt nach kriegen wir auch die red
war zum sonntag treten einigermaßen was
ist original
ton per bus zu warten da auch markus
profitierte vom bruder und seinen ärzten
in körperlicher würde mir natürlich dass
verliebt sich im laufe ihrer
drogenabhängigkeit erstens bevor sie bis
sie natürlich aus stellt kann mit
hepatitis mit hiv und damit natürlich
längerfristig problem ganz klar die
mensch der vor seiner patienten deutlich
reduziert die lebenserwartung im
vergleich zur möglichkeit
nicht dabei getötet
damals erkrankte markus an aids davon
von hiv positiv ist
ist das einfach nur
einen trend in einer super jetzt auch
noch sein mussten
es ist das todesurteil des essays
todesurteil männer ja es ist gemacht
also wieso sehen auch zum drohte also
ick situation alleine
in dem habe dass sie zurückkommen was
ich mir nach
künstlich beatmet
charakter
aus entweder wir stimmen zu der wende
zurück nach
[Musik]
berlin nimmt mich mit in das tonstudio
eines befreundeten musikers jede freie
minute verbringt sie mit ihren
instrumenten
[Musik]
sie bezieht immer noch täglich die
heroin im koma trotzdem ist sie
finanziell unabhängig sie verdient mit
ihrer arbeit in der beiz ihren
lebensunterhalt
ziemlich
rasch auf sie
aber das ist nicht schlecht aber auch
noch bis nächste woche
und der geräte eine verteilung in europa
target
abgebrochenes mehr
professionalität entwickelt ich meine
das im service
ich bin der bürger und alle meine pläne
um über plätze abkochen
denn musik stehen da ist auch die woche
frontex mäßig
suche verantwortlich robert wexler
sensibel presse und andere personen
geboren die man die chance bin also
fleisch beständig
und die bio serie bestehen und eine
ausnahme was es so blut
vorraum
unter dem chor benutzern ist air berlin
eher eine ausnahme
die sieht zwar wichtig aber
geschafft des absoluten moslems leben
verbietet des umfelds harwanne die hmi
legalen bereich oder nur süchtig ist
vorüber sei ich schaffe es zum zeitpunkt
x
63 eigentlich
sei gefragt worden aber
das ist auch das ist ja die frage ist
abstinenz erste cd
gefragt
vielleicht zuerst
das thw kiel oder auf aus partie gewesen
das konnte man einfach
nicht glücklich sondern es ist das
gesamtpaket über schlussendlich gab es
qualität ausmacht
für susann ist abstinenz kein thema seit
acht jahren ist sie nicht mehr im
heroinabgabe programm seither nimmt sie
aber methadon und befriedigt ihre sucht
mit alkohol statt wie früher mit heroin
[Musik]
so gut die betsy kam so cool
aussehen
kurz nach diesem gespräch hat sich
susanne freund rolf
das leben genommen
[Musik]
doch nichts
dafür
vielmehr sei verwandt mit
dem
stand
spät so jetzt am kiosk
und ich mich wichtig das ist
familie smits
zählte sie mal familie h
du bist du mich ob ich drehte
zu genau und ja das ist eben das bedeute
meter dorna und die fehler medikament
das schauen wie fotos
es ist wenn er zwar nie mehr mitmacht
zum beispiel habe das gerät wurde dafür
auch
wenn ihr bis grand place
heute zählt das
untersucht sie tut eine fesche lola
und
das soll dank
nie nie nie nie
[Musik]
auch der 52 jährige markus leidet unter
einsamkeit bei ihm ist es ein aids dass
eine liebesbeziehung fast unmöglich
macht
neben abhängig vom zustand also war das
steve sich
widerstand
[Applaus]
indonesien auftaucht
damit
beauftragt haben etwa micro hat
annecy frankreich gibt bei nachrichten
tiefgang ein relativ roth wichtig denn
12 filtern ist jetzt gar nicht geben
glaubt
jetzt mal hoch
also ich war ja wirklich so
[Musik]
als einziger der vier ehemaligen junkies
ist michele von der sucht völlig
losgekommen er verdient heute als
selbstständiger unternehmer seine
lebensunterhalt sein weg in die
abstinenz war jedoch lang und steinig
erst nach mehreren entzugsversuche fand
er über das methadon programm den weg
zum endgültigen ausstieg
aus
der biskaya
machen
betreue beraubt und sozialamt und raus
eigentlich fast trocken sauber ja die
den zug ist es auch
das wonach halt nach und
hat eigentlich noch ein
projekt
macht
[Applaus]
ja ziemlich leicht durch
eine
chronisch davon stellten
[Musik]
das fahrzeug auf das schnelle songs
kommen auch die schlussendlich harnisch
von hofbauer
das ist wieso
geht beweist ist das geld also
[Musik]
man da irgendwo
aussuchen
[Musik]
mit der materie irgendwann im blut
worden
[Musik]
t
markus ist unterwegs zur hiv
anlaufstelle seine große asien reise
steht bevor er möchte seinen alten traum
verwirklichen und endlich tauchlehrer
werden
hier war es
doch
rocky sie habe jetzt viel medikament mit
wichtig geschäft mit einer medikamente
bäume zu einem kühlschrank aufbewahren
homann trotz weiterhin gut
somit
kann man da sind
alle medikamente für seine krankheit
muss er mitnehmen
vor seiner abreise will sich markus noch
von seiner mutter verabschieden seit ich
ihn kenne pflegt ihr eine enge und
liebevolle beziehung zu seiner mutter
ihr zuhause stand dem auch in den
schlimmsten drogen zeiten stets offen
heute lebt sie im altersheim
prof das
ganze
ab
markus auf der thailändischen insel koh
tao betrifft auf teilnehmer aus aller
welt hier wird es eine tauchausbildung
zu ende bringen
[Applaus]
das ist schon
ganz
andere also das mit dem musiker
aus längst ist ja gottes dass man
faktisch aus
[Musik]
doch so nah dass spezielle folgten das
schwerelose gretel
[Musik]
mischt der
seite sucht der wenn man da wo es
dort überhaupt dass ich sitze nicht so
wird die sucht philharmonie
machen sich ordner
und daher von gaildorf sitzungssäle
meint
also das
[Musik]
zusammentrifft ihre sozialarbeiterin zum
wöchentlichen gespräch sie hat zurzeit
mit ihrer alkoholsucht schwer zu kämpfen
ich muss gar nicht festlegen
gleich einige nase
bewusst worden
aber das ist ja das problem
die vom ausland
heute fast eine blöde frau sei national
und ihnen zu machen ich spüre es wieder
bis bringen
[Musik]
mehr als zehn jahre sind vergangen seit
den anfängen der kontrollierten drogen
abgabe in bern die lebensgeschichten
zwischen ausstieg sucht verlagerung und
rückfall könnten unterschiedlicher kaum
sein
[Musik]
seit über 10 jahren gehört das skoda zum
alltag von evelyn sie fährt heute noch
vor und nach der arbeit in der beiz zur
abgabestelle
sowie evelyn bekommen rund 200 süchtige
im berner coda tag für tag ihr heroin
die kosten werden wie jede andere
ambulante behandlung von der
krankenkasse übernommen
[Musik]
doch noch schaffen
zwischen offenen deprimierende situation
für bösel utopie
ich perspektive nämlich
effektive so ist eine lustige brown
liegt sie hier
jeden tag
schaut
der bürgschaften und
28 in abhängigkeit zum beispiel
etwa 1500 menschen profitieren heute in
der schweiz sowie evelyn von der
kontrollierten heroinabgabe
nur etwa fünf prozent schaffen den
ausstieg und den weg in ein unabhängiges
leben
im gegensatz zu evelyn wechseln die
meisten kutter benutzer im laufe der
zeit von heroin auf methadon sie bleiben
aber finanziell vom staat abhängig und
beziehen iv rente oder sozialgeld
nur ganz wenige bleiben wir berlin
heroinsüchtig und führen dabei ein
geregeltes und finanziell unabhängiges
leben
[Musik]
markus beim tauchen in thailand
sei der vergangenheit holt ihn aber auch
da immer wieder ein
[Applaus]
doch auch nach innen mit doch unter oder
mit trichter ja
ich schaue bei einfachen ausweg sie war
wie einfach nicht
was die situation ist
spezialist für sich die machen zügen ist
das ist dieser job
maschine setzte seine fahrt fort
ohne dass gately
auftragen sieht ist aber sowas ist
bestimmen zähle man vom immer airport
also ich ja doch das ist schon nochmal
medikamenten muss natürlich ein problem
wir haben einfach straße aus in die
ganze oder der kleinste vom
aufgang
wo man einfach wieder
anspringt wenn wir die orte
[Musik]
ja
unbedingt
skate arena
sie haben eine verantwortliche führung
der genannten verantwortlichen
appellieren und schlanken etwa sie unter
dem keine möglichkeit das ist vor allem
wichtig aber dass drogba belang der
stern ich hoffe meine sauber da und weiß
dass sie das nehmen wurden im blut und
das
wasser wird mit optionaler dass sie
verstorben
hätten wir noch bist du und das ist mir
das wichtigste
[Musik]
die drogen für mich hoffentlich nur noch
ein gespenst vergangener zeiten
susan hat sich zwei wochen ferien auf
kreta zusammengespannt
ein freund begleitet sie zum flughafen
[Musik]
ein großer tag für susan aber auch ein
tag voller ängste
ja aber jetzt
schon verzogen
barbara blaine down
neben
[Musik]
doch
berlin ihr ein und alles ist ihre musik
jeweils am feierabend hat sie auch die
musik zu diesem film komponiert
[Musik]
in die rituale sich so
im großen und ganzen was muss auch
österliche reifen
also was ist aber familie
ist vor allem aber
ich weiß auch das
strahlende zähne sauber und bringe
zwischenzeitlich oder bauernhof
ist getümmel stürzen und sagen meine
beziehung zu
ermöglichen
einsamkeit zu suchen
[Musik]
trotz einer weiten reise ins
thailändische paradies ist markus seine
probleme nicht losgeworden
so ist saison die krone gekriegt
problem sieht jahre die griechischen
credit lautet also nicht nur manchmal
einfach mit die ganze situation in
bayern und wie man tut gut
behandelbar woche andere fotogeschenke
sie ist das spielt außer betrieb
es muss endlich begreifen ist alba
verantwortung wenn ich nicht da bin ich
sehr privates freund mitbringen
wegen dieses spiels war es viele doch
irgendwie nach hause muss man ehrlich
sein und sagen ja warte jetzt einfach so
weitermachen
die ganze zwei
mal aber wenn man die ganze ist auch
russland ist marco ja alles lachte für
bandic
[Musik]
das ist alles in ordnung gehe ja man
sparen
bisher im august mit suchen
[Musik]
ja ja
mit dem ich leben
[Musik]
mehr als zehn jahre sind vergangen seit
ich markus michelle susan und evelyn zum
ersten mal getroffen habe vieles hat
sich verändert ihre so unterschiedlichen
schicksale erfüllen mich mit freude und
mit gefühl hinterlassen aber auch
betroffenheit die kontrollierte drogen
abgabe kann vieles vergessen
dass nach gift allerdings die wunden und
narben ihre vergangenheit werden die
ehemaligen junkies wohl ihr leben lang
begleiten
[Musik]